i don't feel
anything i'm just
well i'm upset
really like deep down in my heart
oh
man
i was i was mad
at myself not anyone just like myself
so i gotta get out of here because i'm
mad
like anyone when you're angry you might
do stupid things so i was mad but then i
realized this is sport
let me do the right thing
well our sports presenter elena roper is
here to talk us through the overnight
drama uh eleanor you know i've often
said that anthony joshua is the nicest
most charming
celebrity sportsman i've ever
interviewed what happened i mean he is
all of those things he is lovely he is
charming i think it's just the pressure
um
it's been described as unsportsmanlike
you know sore loser at the end but it's
impossible to imagine the pressure that
he would have been under you know
thousands in attendance millions of
people watching around the world to
not just have lost once now to alexander
usic but twice
um
yeah just a huge amount of pressure on
his shoulders and we saw that afterwards
in the press conference we saw eddie him
with his arm around him and eddie has
actually tweeted since then to say he
just wants joshua to be happy and
actually it'll probably be good for him
to have a bit of a time out without the
you know the pressure and the weight
that comes with these titles
um and and to see what's next for him
and what is next for him is this the end
of it for aunt francis joshua and what
do you think we can read into that
reaction last night yeah i i don't think
we can read too much into it tony bell
you another person who'd commented
afterwards to say you cannot imagine
you know coming coming with a sort of
level-headed response after a 12-round
fight you know it takes everything out
of you enormous build-up
um
just the pressure and i think you know
time will pass we saw there anthony
joshua sort of reflecting on that and
maybe regretting it um clearly really
really upset he'll take some time out
he'll reflect but i'm sure he'll come
again okay elena thank you for now we'll
see you later
well despite the bizarre themes after
the fight had ended the night belonged
to alexander usyk and also symbolized a
victory for his country the 35 year old
was on the front line in kiev as
recently as march halting preparations
for his rematch with joshua as the war
in ukraine began well ukraine's
president zielinski quickly tweeted to
congratulate him saying difficult but so
important and necessary victory
defending the title of world champion is
a symbol that all those who are of
cossack sort will not give up their own
they will fight for it and will
definitely win
usyk then dedicated his win to the
people of ukraine entrenched in their
war
with russia quite an extraordinary story
ukrainians never give up they always go
to the end they always win we're
definitely going to win we just need a
little more time